you're sick of talking about the
election and I apologize but I want to
make sure you see a couple of maps
because I think they're important if you
watch that in the commentary last week
over the election you know that Mitt
Romney the Republican got a huge block
of votes from white older men and
President Obama got votes from women
younger people African Americans Asians
Latinos and that that those set of
blocks that coalition was enough to
overcome the number of votes that Mitt
Romney had but i want you to see some
maps that get it a different slice of
those demographics so what you're
looking at right now is the county by
county breakdown who voted which way
just like the maps you saw on the news
that's a red county's voted for romney
and blue counties voted for obama this
kind of maps called a chloroplast map
it's a divides up geographic areas by
their by some value in this case who
they voted for but you look at this
Clara play and you go well what the hell
happened here because that's mostly red
now what the chloroplast can't show you
in this case is something more important
which is population density so here's a
set of maps that my friend Tim two-shot
did for his blog per square mile he got
hold of this data and what you'll see on
these is that the centers of population
were the places that voted for the
president senators population course is
just a kind of euphemism or synonym for
cities so what happened here well
fundamentally the urban areas voted for
president obama and the rural areas the
non-urban areas broadly defined voted
for romney ok but not exactly we can
drill down to that even more nate silver
the polling wizard who blogs for the New
York Times had this line a couple months
ago he said the heuristic the rule the
heuristic is if a place has sidewalks
and votes for Democrats if it doesn't
votes Republicans and that's a good
heuristic but we can get a little bit
more specific this is the work of a
group called patchwork nation another
old friend guy worked with the Newsweek
a long time ago Dante Chinni does this
and he breaks down the counties into
kind of demographic descriptors to try
to explain their differences so what
happened here was in places that that
patrick nation describes as for example
the money burbs the the really nice
ritzy suburbs of cities or industrial
centers or places that college campuses
those places voted overwhelmingly for
the president for reelection but places
that could be urban but we're also
evangelical centers let's say or in your
military bases voted overwhelmingly for
Mitt Romney but there weren't enough of
those to compensate for the advantage
that the President had so you know I
bang on all the time about how important
cities are but what happened here is
something I think kind of remarkable
especially if you consider that accorded
in the 2000 census seventy-nine percent
of americans lived in cities by 2010
that was eighty point seven now that
doesn't seem like a lot but it does show
a growth trend and when you have 300
million people those fractions and
percentages are a lot what I'm saying is
more and more people are living in
cities and this year in two thousand
twelve cities elected a president